today on the mat well show a Macy's
employee was viciously assaulted on
camera in a racially motivated attack
but you haven't heard about it because
the victim was white but we'll talk
about that today because I think it
should be getting a lot more attention
than it's getting also five headlines
including a male transgender fighter
bragging about how he enjoyed fracturing
the skull of a female fighter plus Teddy
Roosevelt is the latest historical
figure to get his statue torn down and
in today's daily cancellation we're
gonna cancel Brett Favre for calling
Colin Kaepernick a hero and comparing
him the Pat Tillman Pat Tillman by the
way died serving his country
what did Kaepernick sacrifice for his in
order to serve his own cause and what is
his cause I will talk about that daily
cancellation all of it coming up but
first today's show is brought to you by
Bambi look it's it's if you want to have
a good company if you want to company be
successful then you need to have a good
HR department when running a business HR
issues can kill you wrongful termination
suits minimum wage requirements leg
labor regulations are all kinds of all
the red tape and everything you need to
sort through HR manager salaries also
are not cheap an average salary is gonna
be $70,000 a year in this country
Bambi spelled BA MBE was created
specifically for small businesses you
can get a dedicated HR manager you can
craft HR policy maintain your compliance
all for just $99 a month alright so
that's gonna be a lot less expensive
than what it would cost you device to
pay for a full-time HR manager with
Bambi you can change HR from your
biggest liability to your biggest
strength just like that from onboarding
determinations they customize your
policies to fit your business and they
help you manage your employees day to
day all for just $99 a month go to Bambi
comm slash walls right now to schedule
your free HR audit that's Bambi comm
slash Walsh spelled BA MBE e.com slash
Walsh alright
welcome to the show we are broadcasting
live from our summer cottage it's not
really our
summer cottage were just renting it for
a week but and I couldn't find a good
shot so I'm set up in the it's like a
hallway but with a door behind but it's
a nice door nice wooden door so you can
see the kitchen back there very scenic
scenic view you know work it's it's kind
of a vacation kind of a family vacation
although I'm working so it's a work a
working vacation but whenever I go on
vacation with now that I have kids for
kids I can remember being a kid myself
and going on vacation with my parents
and I would always feel very upset and
offended
personally that my parents weren't
working around the clock on vacation to
keep me entertained because I figured
this is vacation I'm supposed to be
having fun so your job mom and dad is to
make sure that I'm having fun all the
time and I can remember that and I never
understood why my parents got so angry
with that attitude and now that I'm an
adult I get it I can see now because
when I go on vacation I you know I can
see yeah my parents they paid all this
money they drove all this way they put
all this effort into it meanwhile
they're the ones who actually need the
vacation because they're the ones with
all the responsibility like I'm a kid I
don't even need a vacay my whole life is
a vacation and you know maybe they
actually want to relax and I don't know
enjoy the time themselves possibly it
turns out they don't want to spend the
whole time being my personal concierge
service or my personal entertainment
coordinator so I see that now because my
kids do exactly what I did when I was a
kid and even though I understood cuz I
did the same thing so I understand where
they're coming from but I still react
the same way my parents did and that's
the vicious cycle just goes on and on
through the generations and it cannot be
stopped anyway we're having a great time
now I want to start with a story that
would be front-page news it would be
headlines on CNN it would be talked
about everywhere this would be the only
thing we're talking about for the next
several days would be I'm probably there
be buildings being burned in protest and
everything if not for one little detail
there's one little detail about this
story that makes it go from headline
news to nobody cares and I'll play the
video for you and tell me if you can
spot what that
detail is watch yes the detail of course
is the skin color reverse the races on
that video and you have breaking news
everywhere you know but as it is with a
white man being the one brutally
assaulted by black men in the middle of
a macy's nobody cares no attention paid
to it well I should say people aren't
paying attention to it now but when the
video first surfaced it got a fair
amount of attention most have been
approving because here's here's here's
the background of that video the scumbag
carrying out the assault there is
apparently named Damir palmer and his
brother the Markway palmer is filming it
the Markway also is an aspiring rapper
turns out to Markway
posted a video on his social media
initially proudly claiming that the man
being attacked whose amazes employee
said the n-word in reference to them and
that's what supposedly led up to this
assault the employee called them the
n-word and then Damir assaulted and with
that version of events this video got
thousands of likes and shares on social
media and most of the people sharing and
commenting were approving of the assault
they were cheering it on they were
laughing now before we get to the part
of this story where it turns out that
the n-word claim was a fabrication it
should be noted that even if he did save
the n-word that obviously doesn't
justify physical assault this is a kind
of a thing this is the kind of thing
that shouldn't need to be explained we
you know I really shouldn't need to add
this aside but that is perhaps the most
disturbing thing by this whole event is
the apparent assumption by many people
that a black person actually has every
right to brutalize another human being
if that human being says a bad word
what kind
absurdity is this a person says a word
and that gives you a license to commit a
felony
how so especially when you consider that
the irony is that the N word was said
about 15 times in that 18 second video
but all by the guy carrying out the
assault so again this should not need to
be said but no you don't have the right
nor are you morally justified in
assaulting someone because they said a
bad word
no not at all not even a little bit the
brother by the way when explaining the
thought process he was he was
interviewed by the New York Post and he
said quote and just the fact of the
remark that he said that we all heard ok
and just what else are we supposed to do
in this age and time he didn't know what
else to do that was just his instinct
talking about his brother Kerry who's
assaulting what else is he supposed to
do in this age and time you know in this
age and time if if he hears a bad word
he just has to commit a felony assault
what up what else does he die there's
there's no other option ok makes perfect
sense
thanks to Mark Lee now the mark Witt
claims that this all started when he and
his brother were just innocently
shopping together going out doing a
little just the boys on a shopping spree
little boys night out and Damir says
that he he put out he took a shirt off
the rack and he put it up to his he
didn't put it on but he put it up to his
to his chest you know and he said to the
employee who was on phone does this
shirt look too little and then the claim
is that the employee said yes and then
turned back to the person on the phone
and said to the person on the phone no
one just some n-word obviously were
freaky the person on the phone said who
was that he said no one just some n-word
he claims that the Macy's employee said
this in the middle of the store casually
while they could easily hear it and that
is obviously bogus just before we go any
further and get to any of the details if
you have a moderately well calibrated BS
detector it should be going haywire
from a story like that sirens going off
blaring everything the story is
completely ridiculous it strains
believability that a Macy's employee
would be that casually and openly racist
on the job and somehow this is the first
time anybody noticed so all you have to
do is think just you know think about
all the times a story like this has been
proven fake and weigh it against the
likelihood that a Macy's employee would
say something like that in that
situation or any other situation and
then and then when you perform that
calculation you end up with by my
estimate approximately eight ninety-nine
point nine nine nine nine nine nine nine
nine nine nine nine nine nine percent
chance that the N word claim is false
and this was an unprovoked assault by
two guys who selected the victim based
on race and then assaulted him and
recorded it so they could go viral as
heroes for racial justice a hate crime
in other words a racially motivated
assault a hate crime and yes it turns
out that's exactly what happened Macy's
has come out and said they investigated
and can confirm this this was an
unprovoked attacked attack and we know
we can trust what they say because now
is not a time when corporations are
willing to go out on a limb to defend
white employees especially what
employees had the n-word if they
actually thought he said it if they had
any reason to think that he said it you
could you could be damn sure they'd be
throwing him under the bus in a second
but they're not because you know they're
gonna have witnesses they're gonna have
security footage not to mention he's not
gonna be on a personal cell phone he's
gonna be on a company phone and those
are probably gonna be recorded lines so
if he was on the phone at all which is
possible he wasn't and the security
footage would tell them that but he was
on the phone they could just listen to
the conversation and see what he said
hear what he said so any number of lines
of evidence could easily reveal the
truth of this situation so Macy's
testimony combined with the plain
absurdity of the brothers claims
combined with the fact that they have no
credibility at all because they are the
assailants in this situation make it
very clear that this is what they said
it's not true it's a hate crime
just a hate crime they assaulted him and
then slandered him on the internet they
beat him down physically and then they
tried to ruin his life on top of it by
putting the video online and saying that
he said a racist word so these are just
too awful human beings and this guy is a
victim twice over yet of course the
outrage is non-existent that's because
the left as we have seen time and again
is not interested in racial equality let
alone racial unity that's the last thing
I want this is this is about this is not
about defeating racism or hatred or
bigotry or intolerance everything we're
seeing now from tearing down the statues
to the riots to the elevation of radical
organizations like BLM it's all about
ideology leftist ideology and the
ideology in in this ideology the white
man is evil always all white men unless
there are communists or gay rights
activists so those are the two
exceptions and I understand there's a
lot of course overlap in those groups
that I mentioned but with those
exceptions all other white men are evil
and it's really as simple as that
inherently evil yeah I think if you're a
white man by leftist ideology if you're
a white man you're already inherently
racist because you're white and that
applies to white women too okay which is
why for example when a white woman is
beaten with two by fours at a BLM
protest protest slash riot which
happened a few weeks ago in this video
of that no outrage over that either
that's another example of something I
mean reverse the races on that just just
imagine imagine for a second really try
to imagine this try to imagine a video
of three white men beating a black woman
with a two-by-four it would still be the
only thing we're talking about in that
event would be used as proof of systemic
racism for decades they'd be going back
to that for
decades yet it happens with with with
the reveille traces how they are and
it's just yeah you know it's unfortunate
maybe maybe not
but yeah we're moving on we're not to
talk about so you think about the
situation a white man is in from the
perspective of a leftist inherently
racist because you're white toxically
masculine because you're a man so now
this is a toxic racist person every
single white man with the two exceptions
I mentioned so yeah you can beat them up
you can kill them you can do whatever
you want in its it gets can't it
certainly can't be a hate crime and
really it's not really a crime at all
least morally and this is listen this is
not an exaggeration or hyperbole this is
this is really the leftist position that
for a long time that wouldn't state
explicitly but now they're starting to
basically state it explicitly and there
is no other explanation for this
dichotomy for how you know a video like
the one that I just played for you could
get no reaction from the left whatsoever
none they just don't care period why
because he's a white man alright we're
gonna move on to headlines here number
one Fallon Fox you may you may remember
the name Fallon Fox he was the
biological male MMA fighter who
identified as a woman and was allowed to
fight as one and during his career he
assaulted several female fighters and
this is assault when it's a man in the
ring doesn't belong there then it's not
just a fight it's assault he fractured
the skulls of at least one of them well
a few days ago on Twitter if you're
thinking that maybe he feels some
remorse or embarrassment after he's
retired and it's been a few years
looking back on it and thinking hey
maybe I shouldn't have been in there
with women fracturing their skulls no
not at all he's he's still gloating
about it in fact here's a tweet from
Fallon Fox that he sent out a couple
days ago it says for the record I
knocked two out two women that is
one woman's skull was fractured the
other not and just so you know I enjoyed
it
see I love smacking up turfs misspells
it I love smacking up turfs in the cage
who talked transphobic nonsense
it's bliss don't be mad okay so to
review on this we've got a man talking
about fracturing the skull of a woman
and saying that not only did he enjoy it
but it's bliss
it is euphoria for him just to fracture
a woman's skull you think we're gonna
get any condemnation from over this from
the LGBT Lobby or the media of course
not
because you know this is it's it's all
about the the victim hierarchy and as a
transgender non-white male he is all the
way at the top he's at the tippy tippy
top of the victim hierarchy and there's
he can do whatever he wants you
literally do whatever he wants and you
cannot criticize any of it to even to
the point of fracturing a woman's skull
and bragging about it number two let's
read from The Daily wire Eskimo pies has
become the latest brand making an effort
to change its image images following the
outrage that ensued over and Jemima
syrup the frozen treat which is owned by
parent company Dreyer's grande ice cream
released a statement Friday announcing
it would change the name according to
the New York Post it says we are
committed to being a part of the
solution on racial equality and
recognize the term is derogatory this
move is part of a larger review to
ensure our company and brands reflect
our people values along with the name
change the company will alter the treats
marketing scheme which traditionally
feature a young boy dressed as an Eskimo
in a snowy environment they just said
it's a derogatory term and they use the
term in in their apology statement they
use the term they just said was
derogatory there's a dragger draaga Tory
term we will are never going to use it
again by the way that that picture of an
Eskimo boy we're gonna change that too
why is Eskimo derogatory
what's derogatory about it
well there's there's nothing of course
but this is this is how PC culture works
you just you you just randomly change
the names of things and it becomes sort
of a you know becomes sort of a litmus
test that's the word I'm going for with
phrase and gopher
it's a litmus test if you're just to
keep where to randomly arbitrarily
change the names of things every every
you know few years or so and if you're
really woke and progressive you're gonna
be up to date on the new terms it's kind
of like a club do you know the the
secret passwords to get in and that's
just it's a good litmus test to know who
the woke people are it meanwhile as
we're doing this we're also told that
representation matters that's the other
slogan so we're taking all these
products where you've got minorities who
are represented on the products and as
the face of the product and we're taking
them off it's the same thing they did
with the Land O'Lakes butter they took
the Native American woman off the butter
so isn't that less representation how is
this an improvement by their own logic
number three a statue of Teddy Roosevelt
is being removed from the Natural
History Museum in New York Mayor Bill
DeBlasio said in a statement the
American Museum of Natural History has
asked to remove the Theodore Roosevelt
statue because it explicitly depicts
black and indigenous people as
subjugated and racially inferior the
city supports the museum's request it is
the right decision and the right time to
remove this problem this problematic
statue the statue is so causing so many
problems
what problems is it actually causing
it's a statue it's just sitting there
it's been sitting there for 80 years
stationary hasn't hurt anybody as far as
I know isn't that like night of the
museum where it comes to life and and
stab somebody just sitting there just a
statue but the important thing here is
you know how we've been told for so long
that oh we're not trying to get rid of
the statues we just we're going to put
them in a museum and and they could be
there we don't need them in the middle
of the town square we could just put in
the museum so this isn't about erasing
history no we're gonna put everything in
a museum
and they circle back around and say oh
by the way that stuff in the museum
that's got to go too
so it's very similar to what the left
does with religious liberty where for so
long they were trying to remove religion
from the public square and telling you
you can't practice your religion in the
public square or or run your business
according to your religious beliefs as
the masterpiece cake shop owner
discovered but what they always said was
no we're not trying to get rid of
religion no no no don't be silly
we're just saying you should do it in a
church you see because we we get to
decide that we get to decide series
talking to me again
shut up Siri we get to decide as leftist
we have to decide where you do these
things for summary we're not going to
explain why we have that right we just
do but then what do they do they circle
back back around and say yeah actually
that's it's not really appropriate in a
church either so it's the same thing
here and eventually you hope that the
right kind of catches on at some point
it's been decades maybe at some point
the conservative movement will catch on
and realize what the strategy is because
how many conservatives have gone along
with this with the Confederate monuments
or anything else and said yeah they're
right there you know they're being
reasonable they're being totally there
you've got crazed mobs tearing down
statues setting them on fire throwing
them in lakes but they're being
reasonable this is a reasonable thing
they they just want they wanted in a
museum yeah it's at the bottom of a lake
now I just gotta dig it out we got a you
know bring in bringing some equipment
drag it out of the lake put any museum
that's all I'm trying do they meant to
put her in a museum but they act they
accidentally dropped in a lake on the
way they were bringing it to the museum
on the way on the way they accidentally
set it on fire threw in a lake you see
so many conservatives just love being
duped it's something I'm convinced it's
almost a fetish or something for them at
this point
they love being duped lied to abused
it's it's getting creepy it's weird at
this point no no this it's it's always a
lie it's always incremental okay we're
getting rid of this we're moving it here
oh it can't be there
oh we're gonna move it over here can't
be there either we're gonna move here on
and on until it ends up at the bottom of
the lake now I want to read this reports
to you from Yahoo News there are a few
things in this center that are
interesting reading from Yahoo News
headline is a search for answers after
deputies kill brother a black man found
hanging from tree says Terron Boone was
distraught when his youngest brother was
found hanging from a tree in a park near
Palmdale City Hall last week the manner
of death of the 24 year old Robert
Fuller evoked ugly images of the
nation's racist legacy of lynchings and
sparked outrage when Los Angeles County
coroner's and sheriff's officials
quickly listed it as a suicide protests
generated national attention and
prompted local authorities to involve
state and federal investigators taking a
timeout here just on this there have
been a couple of cases recently of black
men found hanging from trees and what
what the media and Democrats are doing
with these cases is grotesque even by
their demonic standards the reason why
these are quickly categorized as
suicides is because suicides are
unfortunately very common in America and
law enforcement officials deal with them
all the time and if something is a
suicide most of the time it's really
obvious right away the difference
between a suicide and someone being
murdered it's really clear to forensic
investigators and they can tell quickly
that's why this isn't that's not a
conspiracy so when you find someone
hanging it's a terrible very disturbing
sad tragic thing of course but
unless there is very good evidence that
this person was was murdered that way
there's no reason to assume it and
considering death by not only a suicide
extremely common
tragically common but death by hanging
is one of the most common forms of
suicide so that's why these are suicides
yet you've got the media and Democrats
macmail Camilla Harris sent out a tweet
a lot of Democrats have but implying
implying that there you know there could
there's something else going on here
what what out what even is the theory if
it's not a suicide are you saying that
there are gangs of literal lynch mobs
forming and killing people and nobody
notices it doesn't get on there's no
footage of it no one catches it on
camera that's that's not really
something that can be done discreetly
now suicide again tragically is done
discreetly all the time it's always done
discreetly almost always anyway because
if that's how it happens otherwise
someone would have stopped it
so yes suicide is what you would expect
what you expect is you know you just
someone commits suicide and and and you
stumble upon the carnage right with a
with a lynch mob that is not at all what
you would expect so unless there is
really really good evidence that these
were not suicides the assumption
obviously is going to be that it's a
suicide anyway back to the article says
then on Wednesday exactly a week after
his brother's body was found
boom 31 was shot and killed by Los
Angeles County sheriff's deputies and
what authorities described as a wild
shootout in this desert town north of
Palmdale the shooting ended a bizarre
series of events in which authorities
accused Boone of pistol whipping
imprisoning and threatening a former
girlfriend over a week-long period it's
unclear what if any connection Boone's
shooting had to his brother's death and
many questions remain now I want to get
to what a in activist who's protesting
all of this so you've got here's what we
have a suicide and then someone getting
into a shoot committing a series of
horrible crimes and getting into a
shootout with
and I'm there's really nothing here to
protest there's plenty to mourn there's
plenty to be very sad about there's
nothing to probe what are we protesting
well Isabelle flax a 24 year old
activist from Lancaster said at a new
news conference on Thursday morning
demanding justice for fuller she said
another name who wants another name
another hashtag to Ron his brother
another name who cares the circumstance
it doesn't even matter what he did
anymore it doesn't matter what they do
anymore it does not matter doesn't
matter what they do so if so you're
saying that if this man got into a
shootout with cops and was shooting at
them and he shot and he's killed in the
process it's still an outrage and that
doesn't matter we have reached a point
hey this is the point we've reached
where anytime a police officer kills a
black man under any circumstance it she
said it herself under it is always
racism doesn't matter that they could be
shooting at the cops this could be clear
self-defense
gunfire being exchanged it's racism in
order for the cop to not be racist he
would have to drop his gun and just
offer himself up to be killed this again
is not hyperbole this is what you just
heard from the activists doesn't matter
the circumstance absolute lunacy v
finally there was a trump rally in Tulsa
over the weekend you probably heard
about that there's a lot of controversy
about the crowd sighs and about the the
you know Trump said whatever Trump said
and blah blah blah who cares don't care
about any of that instead what I'm
focusing on is something that happened
right before Trump came out at the rally
this is really the headline in my
opinion watch this
[Music]
this is why John Lithgow had the right
idea in Footloose dancing should be
banned that's always been my position
and I think right there you see the
ramifications the catastrophe that can
ensue if you allow dancing willy-nilly
now I wanna make clear under my regime
it's not that nobody will ever be
allowed to dance
I wouldn't do that that would be you
know I'm not a tyrant who I am but I'm
not this I'm not saying you can't have
dancing for me it only licensed
professionals will be allowed to dance
and to get a license you'll have to
submit an application a resume an
audition video which I will review and
then you'll obtain a license but the
license will only be good for one one
Episode one bout of dancing and then and
then if you want to dance again you'll
have to go through the review process
again so if you're at a wedding
reception let's say and you want to
dance tell it you know let's say six
different songs you can dance to one go
through the light the licensing process
again dance to the other and so wedding
receptions will take probably seven or
eight weeks to be done once all the red
tape is cleared and everything all right
let's move to daily cancellation
actually before we there's one other
thing I forgot to mention so we'll do
this is a bonus bonus headline here I
did I just I did want to just touch on
this briefly this is the tweet from the
AP which went out this morning it says
NASCAR says a noose was found in the
garage stall of Bubba Wallace at a
NASCAR race in Alabama Wallace the only
full-time black driver in NASCAR's elite
Cup Series successfully pushed for
NASCAR to ban the Confederate flag at
his track and properties so saying a
noose was found there look I don't know
the specifics of this but what we do
know is that these stories about nooses
are almost always hoaxes I can't think
of a recent example it wasn't a hoax I'm
not saying there hasn't been a read just
I can't think of one maybe there's been
a couple but vast majority when you hear
about a when you hear a story about a
noose you hear story about a racist note
left on a receipt
you hear story about racist graffiti
almost always hoaxes vast majority of
cases in recent history are hoaxes so
the assumption is going to be contrary
to we played that the clip of the
Oakland mayor last week saying that we
should just assume hate crime from the
beginning contrary to that actually we
should do the opposite we should assume
it's not a hate crime we should assume
it's a hoax until good evidence is given
to the contrary and so with this I'm you
know I may be it happened but much much
greater chance of it being a hoax or
some kind of I don't know or
misinterpretation of something else or
who knows but to assume this and by the
way there's gonna be this is a nascar
garage so there's gonna be cameras all
over the place
whatever happened we'll know in short
order okay let's go to our daily
cancellation today we are canceling and
actually before we do that I have to
stop one more time and tell you about
the daily wire readers pass if you're
not already a daily wire I remember you
should consider getting a reader's pass
to daily wire calm it's a great value
for only three dollars a month and when
you sign up you get the first month for
only 99 cents you also get access to our
mobile app articles ad free and you can
access exclusive editorials like this
one for example this is the latest one
that I have up white privilege is a myth
here's how privilege really works in
America a lot of reaction to that much
of it at least on social media has been
extremely negative so if you want to see
what all the fuss is about you can get a
reader's pass and read that if you
haven't checked out the readers pass
already go to daily wire comm and sign
up for just a book all right daily
cancellation today we're canceling Brett
Favre and we're canceling him for this
do you look at Colin Kaepernick you know
people look at him and it's like a
Jackie Robinson or a Muhammad Ali is
Colin Kaepernick someone that belongs in
Canton someday for what he did obviously
led a team to a Super Bowl but also for
all he's done off the field bless us
that he is he's helped us call us
tremendously and his deserving of of
much praise and respect but just it's
not easy for a guy his age black and
white Hispanic whatever just stop
something that you've always dreamed of
do it and put it on hold maybe forever
it for something that you believe in you
know I can only think of right off the
top I had Pat Tillman's another guy who
did something you know similar and and
we regard him as a hero so I assume that
hero status will will be stamped with
with Kaepernick as well Oh Brett you had
yet you just had and is probably this
was part of an interview with TMZ I
don't know what else happened in the
interview I assume he didn't come on
just to talk about Kaepernick or racial
issues at all but you know it if you're
someone like like Brett Favre you're an
athlete and you're not and you don't
want to get involved this stuff you just
have to not do any interviews at all
because you're gonna get asked and if
you don't have the cojones to speak the
truth
then I would just I would decline all
interview requests if I was someone like
Brett Favre because then this is what
happens saying that Kaepernick is a hero
on the level of Pat Tillman there's no
way he believes that and you could tell
even while he's saying it he doesn't
believe it you can tell even in his face
while he's saying it he doesn't believe
that any wishes he wasn't saying what
he's currently saying first of all to
this idea that Kaepernick was some kind
of great player and can come back to
football after four years and be
effective let's remember that he
discovered his passion for social
justice once his star had already faded
after a pretty abysmal 2015 campaign
where he lost six out of eight games
that he played he posted only six
touchdowns against five interceptions
he's been out of the league since 2016
the same year that that you know the
anthem protest started he went one in
ten that season when something like 2000
passing
16 touchdowns got beat out for the
starting job by Blaine Gabbert so he was
not a good football player he wasn't the
worst
he was like his mediocre pretty bad but
mediocre four years later he's not gonna
be better
you don't mediocre football players
don't leave football and come back four
years later better Michael Vick was the
biggest star in the NFL he left for two
years cuz he was in prison he came back
and was was really good for like two
years but then he fell off the face of
the earth after that but he was as I
said the star of the whole league and he
was also I think younger when he came
back and he was only gone for two years
Colin Kaepernick is not Colin Kaepernick
was with his style of play was like a
generic michael vick michael vick
without the same athleticism without the
arm strength so he's not gonna come back
and begin he good that's why he's not
getting a job because he's gonna be
mediocre at best
that's that's the most you could
possibly in a miracle situation he would
be mediocre even that's probably not
gonna be so if you're if you're an NFL
team you're gonna take on a guy who's
not gonna be good and at best he's a
second-stringer third-string he's
bringing all this drama and baggage with
him all of the wrong kind of attention
because you're trying to play football
you're not you know you're not looking
to be the center of some sort of
controversy and everything and you know
that if he doesn't get the starting job
you're gonna be accused of being racist
and if you give him the starting job and
he's terrible then he loses ten games
again and you try to bench him you're
gonna be called racist no matter what
you do you're racist so from a coach's
perspective why in the world would you
ever hire this guy and I say all of that
and we know he is now gonna get hired by
someone because the NFL is gonna force
some team to do it we know that's gonna
happen
as for him being a hero like Pat Tillman
I mean Pat Tillman left football and
died serving his country overseas so he
gave up football and
in exchange died he gave up his life
what what did Kaepernick get in exchange
for giving up football
hats Hillman got death okay
Kaepernick got agile ation and praise
from all over the media and the left and
Hollywood and everything which he's
which he's still alive to enjoy he got
more Fame and oh yeah he got multi
millions of dollars
I mean he's making tens and tens of
millions of dollars largely on the basis
of being this social justice hero
supposed hero so no this is not a
sacrifice like pastilla but then again I
don't I don't need to sit here
explaining why Brett Favre is wrong
because Brett Favre knows why he's wrong
and yet is just saying this anyway
because he feels like he has to and
that's why Brett Favre is canceled we
have another situation of he did
something to avoid being cancelled but
he's getting cancelled anyway granted
from his perspective you know he'd
probably be rather be cancelled by me a
podcast host than by you know all of the
media and Hollywood and millions of
people he probably prefer to get this
cancellation that I'm billing out but
still in principle for the principle of
it for the record
he is cancelled and we will leave it
there thanks thanks for watching
everybody thanks for listening Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
our supervising producers are Mathis
Glover and Robert Sterling our technical
producer is Austin Stevens edited by
Dani D'Amico and our audio is mixed by
Robyn Fenderson
the Matt Walsh show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20 if
you prefer facts over feelings aren't
offended by the brutal truth and you can
still laugh at the insanity filling our
national news cycle well tune in to the
Ben Shapiro show we'll get a whole lot
of that and much more see you there